vous le savez
le renforcement massif des moyens de la
justice
et ma priorité absolue
il faut dire que
l'héritage de ces 30 dernières années
n'est pas encore soldé
la route sera longue
mais mon CAP est celui de cette majorité
est extrêmement claire
se donner enfin les moyens
d'une justice qui réponde enfin aux
attentes de nos compatriotes
une justice plus rapide plus efficace
plus protectrice une justice à la
hauteur de ce que doit être
ce grand service public qui fonde notre
pacte social
c'est cela que nos concitoyens appellent
de leurs vœux et c'est cela que le
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
propose grâce à la volonté du Président
de la République et de la première
ministre
en effet
après deux hausses de plus de 8% en 2021
et en 2022 le projet de budget que j'ai
l'honneur de venir vous présenter
aujourd'hui devrait permettre
d'autoriser une troisième hausse
consécutive de plus de 8 % au profit de
notre justice ce sont ainsi
710 millions d'euros supplémentaires
qui viendrait être abondé en 2023 le
service public de la justice qui
s'élèverait à
9,6 milliards d'euros pour l'année 2023
ces moyens importants permettront
d'alimenter les trois grands axes de ma
politique
plus 9% pour les services judiciaires
pour atteindre
3,39 milliards d'euros pour 2023
plus de 7% de hausse des crédits
consacrés à l'administration
pénitentiaire soit un budget de
3,91 milliards d'euros pour 2023 je sais
que c'est un enjeu sensible pour vous
monsieur le Président Houlier
plus de 10% au bénéfice de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse atteignant
donc
917 millions d'euros pour 2023
je sais que c'est pour beaucoup d'entre
nous madame la députée Cécile Hunter un
enjeu majeur